This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. The whole premise, the whole conceit of this show is that if you look at the world in the right way, you'll see stories everywhere. Some of these stories are epic, power struggles chronically in the construction of a world-famous skyscraper or the founding of a city, but other stories are more modest, smaller, in scope, and scale. We call those mini stories.
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马尔斯。这个节目的整体前提、核心构思就是，如果你用正确的方式看待世界，你就会发现到处都是故事。其中有些故事是史诗级的，比如围绕着世界著名摩天大楼的建设或城市的建立而展开的漫长权力斗争，但另一些故事则更加朴素，范围和规模较小。我们把这些称为迷你故事。
Mini stories are an end of the year tradition where 99 PI producers and friends of the show join me on Mike to tell me about something cool. That's all I want. I want to hear something cool, something fun, something that you could tell your friends or family during a holiday get together. Speaking of family, I have someone here with me, please tell these
迷你故事是年末传统，99 PI 的制作人们和节目的朋友们会和我一起连线麦克风，跟我讲一些酷炫的事情。这就是我想要的全部。我想听点酷的、有趣的，或者你可以在节日聚会上讲给朋友或家人听的事情。说到家人，我这里有个人，请向这些
nice people who you are. I'm Lee Mars, I'm your big sister. What do you do besides that? When I'm not big sistering you, I write books or I've written a book about silence. The book is called Golden, the power of silence in a world of noise. And so it is about silence, about why it's important, about what it is, and how to find it in any situation. So it was an example of finding silence in any situation. So this is not a book for people running off to retreats, and silent retreats, for example, for months on end. This is really about finding silence in the midst of a noise-soaked,
好心人自我介绍一下。我是莉·马尔斯，我是你亲姐姐。除此之外你还做些什么？当我不当你的大姐姐时，我写书，或者说我写过一本关于寂静的书。这本书叫《黄金：喧嚣世界中的寂静力量》。所以它是关于寂静的，关于它为什么重要，它是什么，以及如何在任何情况下找到它。所以这是一个关于在任何情况下找到寂静的例子。所以这不是一本给那些动不动就去隐修、去参加静修营长达数月的人看的书。这其实是关于在充满噪音、
dizzy, full life. Something you might know something about, something I know something about, something I co-authored just and certainly know something about. And what kind of noise are we talking about? So the noise we look at in the world is auditory that which happens in our ears, informational that which comes at us usually through our screens, informational that which comes at us usually through our screens and internal that which happens inside internal chatter, rumination, worry about the future, fretting about the past. So I was reading your book and I'm getting a lot out of it, especially the sections about silencing your inner chatter because my inner chatter is very loud.
令人头晕目眩的忙碌生活中找到寂静。这事你可能有所耳闻，我也略知一二，而且我还是合著者，当然对此很清楚。我们在谈论什么样的噪音呢？所以我们审视的世上的噪音包括听觉噪音——发生在耳朵里的那些，信息噪音——通常通过屏幕扑面而来的那些，以及内部噪音——发生在内部的那些，即内心喋喋不休、反刍思维、对未来的担忧、对过去的焦虑。所以我在读你的书，并且受益匪浅，尤其是关于让内心安静下来的那些章节，因为我的内心非常吵闹。
And I came across this example that is a perfect little design-related 99PI mini-story, and it's about the loudness of emergency sirens. Can you tell us about that? So we use emergency vehicles as a proxy indicator for how loud the surrounding environment is, because it has to pierce through the surrounding din in order to get our attention, right? So the composer and environmentalist, Armory Schaefer, found that fire engine sirens in 1912 reached about 96 decibels when measured 11 feet away.
然后我遇到了这个例子，它是一个完美的设计相关的小型 99PI 迷你故事，讲的是紧急警报器的响度。你能给我们讲讲这个吗？所以我们把紧急车辆作为衡量周围环境有多吵的替代指标，因为它们必须穿过周围的喧嚣才能引起我们的注意，对吧？因此，作曲家兼环保主义者阿姆里·谢弗发现，1912 年在距离 11 英尺处测量时，消防车的警报器达到了大约 96 分贝。
And then in 1974, it reached 114 decibels at 11 feet away, that same distance. Bianca Boscher or a journalist recently looked at the Sounds of Sirens, Modern Day Sirens, and found that they reached up to 123 decibels at about that same distance. That might not sound like a big increase, 96 to 114 to 123, but that's on a logarithmic scale. So that means that it's an exponential increase. Every 10 decibels is 10 times the sound pressure to the ears and twice is loud in our experience of hearing it.
而在 1974 年，在同样的 11 英尺距离处，它达到了 114 分贝。记者比安卡·博舍最近研究了现代警报器的声音，发现它们在大致相同的距离下高达 123 分贝。这听起来可能不算很大的增加，从 96 到 114 再到 123，但这是在对数标尺上的。这意味着它是指数级增长。每增加 10 分贝，对耳朵来说就是 10 倍的声音压力，在我们听觉体验中就是两倍响。
So from 1912 to 2019, the siren levels have increased sixfold. They're six times louder. So that shows you how loud it's become in that surrounding environment that our sirens have to be six times as loud to get our attention. That's so cool. OK, so tell everyone again the name of the book.
因此，从 1912 年到 2019 年，警报器的分贝水平增加了六倍。它们的声音响了六倍。这向你展示了周围环境变得有多吵，以至于我们的警报器必须大声六倍才能引起我们的注意。太酷了。好了，请大家再告诉一遍书名。
It's called Golden, the power of silence in a world of noise written by your big sister, Lee Mars, and Justin Zorn, my other brother. What? Get out. And with that, the 2022-2023 mini-stories are underway. You'll hear about a very, very long escalator, beaver, strapping from the sky.
它叫《黄金：喧嚣世界中的寂静力量》，由你的大姐姐莉·马尔斯和我的另一个兄弟贾斯汀·佐恩合著。什么？别开玩笑了。随着这个话题，2022-2023 年的迷你故事正式拉开帷幕。你们将听到关于一条非常非常长的自动扶梯、海狸，以及从天而降的绑缚。
We hear from Janet, Miss Jackson, if you're nasty, and a visit from the Queen. Let's go. So I'm here with producer Chris Perubbe, Higris. Roman, it is the most wonderful time of the year. It is fantastic. So what do you got for me? So my many stories about Queen Elizabeth, who died this year back in September. And of course, being Canadian, it's something I heard about a lot. It was something everybody was talking about for a solid month.
我们将听到珍妮的声音，珍妮·杰克逊（如果你觉得恶劣的话），还有女王的来访。我们开始吧。我现在和制作人克里斯·佩鲁贝在一起，嗨，克里斯。罗曼，这是这一年中最美妙的时光。太棒了。那你给我准备了什么？所以我的迷你故事是关于今年 9 月去世的伊丽莎白女王的。当然，作为一个加拿大人，这是我听说了无数次的事。这是整整一个月里每个人都在谈论的话题。
Right. Right. Because I don't know if I really fully understand the relationship between the Queen and Canadians. But so what is she to you exactly? Yeah, she was Canada's head of state, which is a little esoteric to be honest. I mean, she's on the money. She wasn't really that present and day-to-day life. I mean, it used to be different. It used to be, you know, you look at pictures of old hockey games and during the national anthem,
没错。没错。因为我不知道我是否真的完全理解女王和加拿大人之间的关系。那么她对你来说到底意味着什么？是的，她是加拿大的国家元首，老实说这有点深奥。我的意思是，她的头像印在钞票上。她在日常生活中其实并没有那么大存在感。我的意思是，过去情况有所不同。过去你会发现，你知道的，看老冰球比赛的照片，在国歌响起时，
all the players are, you know, looking up at a painting of the queen during the national anthem. But mostly for Canadians, especially in the 21st century, the only times we really thought about her were during royal visits, like when she would come to visit Canada. And that's actually what I wanna talk about today
所有的球员都在，你知道的，在国歌响起时抬头看着一幅女王的画像。但对加拿大人来说，尤其是在 21 世纪，我们真正会想到她的唯一时间就是在皇家访问期间，比如她来加拿大访问的时候。而这实际上就是我今天要谈论的
is one of those. Oh, fantastic, okay, hit me. Okay, so back in 2002, the queen came by mild workplace, the CBC. And this is before I worked there, I did not get to meet the queen, but I've spoken to a couple of people who were involved, and they all tell me it was pretty intense.
其中一次。哦，太棒了，好的，说来听听。好的，早在 2002 年，女王曾造访我温和的工作场所——加拿大广播公司（CBC）。这是在我去那儿工作之前，我没有机会见到女王，但我跟几个参与其中的人聊过，他们都告诉我当时情况相当紧张。
Like, they were preparing for this thing for months in advance. She only has, like, I might be 12 minutes or eight to 12 minutes, but there's been a year of preparation up. We need a bathroom built on that floor in case the queen has to fart or whatever. Okay, so this is Luciano Casamiri. He's a comedy writer and back in 2002,
比如，他们提前几个月就在为这事做准备。她大概只待，呃，我可能是 12 分钟或者 8 到 12 分钟，但前期准备了一整年。我们得在那层楼建个洗手间，以防女王需要放屁什么的。好吧，这位是卢西亚诺·卡萨米里。他是一名喜剧编剧，早在 2002 年，
he was working at the CBC. And all this prep is going on and his boss comes up to him and says, Hey, we need a writer to work on the event. And Luciano was like, well, that's confusing. Like, why would you need a comedy writer? I don't plan events. And his boss says, well, we need somebody to write all the dialogue.
他在 CBC 工作。所有的这些筹备工作正在进行，他的老板走过来对他说：“嘿，我们需要一个编剧来参与这个活动。”卢西亚诺当时想，这太让人困惑了。比如，为什么你需要一个喜剧编剧？我又不是策划活动的。他的老板说，我们需要有人来写所有的对话。
All the dialogue for like a real life visit. What does that mean? Right. So the boss tells him, okay, everything that is going to be said to the queen during this visit, it must be written out in advance and we are going to send all the dialogue to Buckingham Palace. For like approval. Oh my goodness. I know. So, okay, his job was to write dialogue for 30 people who worked at the CBC. These
为一场现实生活中的访问写所有的对话？这是什么意思？没错。所以老板告诉他，好吧，这次访问期间对女王说的每一句话，都必须提前写好，我们要把所有的对话都送到白金汉宫。为了获得批准之类的。噢天哪。我知道。所以，好吧，他的工作是为 30 个在 CBC 工作的人写对话，这些
are regular people that they were going to say to the Queen of England. So what kind of dialogue is he writing? Yeah, Luciano explained a typical back and forth to me and the way he described it, like it sounded pretty boilerplate. This is Chris, he's writer, he's a podcaster and he's been with us for 17 years.
都是普通人，他们将对英国女王说这些话。那他写的是什么样的对话呢？是的，卢西亚诺向我解释了一段典型的对白，照他的描述，听起来挺像样板文件的。这是克里斯，他是一名作家，也是播客制作人，在我们这儿工作 17 年了。
And it's still Chris, it's been nice to meet you. What exactly is a podcaster and he's been with us for 17 years. And it's still, Chris, it's been nice to meet you. What exactly is a podcast? And then you would go off script. It's like radio and it's, you know, all us nerds do it. It's crazy. You should do it. Well, he's got us picked. Yeah, 100%. So for like a month, Luciano's writing this dialogue for 30 people and he's sending it to Buckingham Palace and they're coming back with these notes. You can't hunger, you can't get a selfie with her. Unless she asks for one.
还是克里斯，很高兴见到你。播客到底是什么？他在我们这儿工作 17 年了。还是，克里斯，很高兴见到你。播客到底是什么？然后你就会脱稿。这就像广播，你知道的，我们这些书呆子都在做。这太疯狂了。你也应该做一个。好吧，他选中了我们。对，百分之百。所以大概一个月里，卢西亚诺都在为这 30 个人写台词，并把它们发给白金汉宫，然后他们带着这些意见回来了。你不能挨饿，你不能和她自拍。除非她主动要求。
One of the protocols that still blows away is they tell you, oh, don't ask if the jewels are real because they're real. That is hilarious. Okay, so this just brings to mind a ton of questions. Like, is this how it is all the time? Yeah, me too. So many questions. First question, obviously, is everybody who meets her reading
其中一个至今让我大跌眼镜的规矩是，他们会告诉你，哦，别问珠宝是不是真的，因为它们绝对是真的。这太搞笑了。好吧，这简直引发了一连串的问题。比如，一直都是这样的吗？是的，我也是。有太多问题了。第一个问题显然是，所有见到她的人都在
on the script, right? How much does she know about this? Is the Queen living inside the Truman Show? Like, do you remember the movie The Truman Show? I did, I saw it originally when it came out. Good morning! Morning! Good morning!
照着剧本读吗？对吧？她对这事了解多少？女王是不是住在《楚门的世界》里？比如，你还记得电影《楚门的世界》吗？记得，它刚上映的时候我就看过。早安！早安！早安！
Oh and in case I don't see you, good afternoon, good evening and good night. Yeah, yeah. Morning Truman! Morning Spencer! Jim Carrey is inside of a TV show, but in that case he doesn't, everyone else knows it, but he doesn't know it. Like she could be the Truman of the Truman show or she could be in it, I don't know.
哦，如果再也见不到你，祝你下午好，傍晚好，晚安。对，对。早安，楚门！早安，斯宾塞！金·凯瑞身处一个电视节目中，但在那种情况下他并不知道，其他人全都知道，但他自己不知道。就像她可能是楚门世界里的楚门，或者她只是身处其中，我不知道。
Yeah, exactly. So, I asked Luciano and he doesn't know, right? He only knows that this one time, he had to write dialogue for the Queen. So, when I heard that the Queen died, I first heard the story about 10 years ago and I decided, you know what, I gotta get to the bottom of this.
对，没错。所以，我问了卢西亚诺，他也不知道，对吧？他只知道就那一次，他必须为女王写对话。所以，当我听说女王去世时，我大约在 10 年前第一次听到这个故事，我决定，你知道吗，我一定要打破砂锅问到底。
Like, how common was this for the Queen? Excellent. So what did you do? Well, first off, I actually called Buckingham Palace. Yeah, I didn't know you could actually just call it, but yeah, I heard of it. Yeah, they actually have this public phone number for journalists. So if you have a press inquiry, you can just call and ask Buckingham Palace a question. And the rules are, you can't record. So I was not allowed to record that. So I called them up and I'm like, Hey, you know, weird question. Did the queen live inside
比如，这种情况对女王来说有多普遍？太棒了。那你做了什么？首先，我其实给白金汉宫打了电话。对，我不知道你居然真的能打通，但没错，我听说过。是的，他们实际上为记者设有一个公开的电话号码。所以如果你有媒体垂询，你完全可以打电话向白金汉宫提问。但规定是，你不能录音。所以我当时是不被允许录音的。所以我打过去然后说：“嘿，你知道的，有个奇怪的问题。女王是住在
the Truman show? And they're like, we'll get back to you on that. And they obviously haven't gotten back to me on that. So my next step is I decided I was going to email people who had met the queen on royal visits. So people who were in photos with the queen. So I emailed a bunch and within an hour I actually heard back from somebody and I'm kind of surprised he got back to me. Hello John Manley speaking. Oh hello, this is Chris Buribay. Miss, your honor, the honorable John Manley, I'm sorry, what do I actually call you?
《楚门的世界》里吗？”他们的反应是：“我们会就此给您回复的。”他们显然并没有给我回复。所以我的下一步决定是，给那些在皇家访问中见过女王的人发电子邮件。也就是那些和女王合过影的人。所以我发了一大堆邮件，不到一个小时我就收到了某人的回复，我其实有点惊讶他会回复我。您好，我是约翰·曼利。哦，您好，我是克里斯·布里贝。参议员，阁下，尊贵的约翰·曼利，抱歉，我到底该怎么称呼您？
No, whatever you want. It doesn't matter. Your honor, the Honorable John Manley, I'm sorry, what do I actually call you? No, whatever you want. Okay, so the Honorable John Manley was the deputy prime minister of Canada from 2002 to 2003, and during the Royal Visit in 2002, he was the Queen's Escort when she visited Parliament Hill, which sounds very official, but according to him, the whole experience was, it was kind of a little uninspiring. I met her at the aircraft. I was in the motorcade, but there's not a lot to do. There's not a lot of opportunity to talk with her, to be with her. I mean, you don't travel with the Queen.
不，随你便。没关系。阁下，尊贵的约翰·曼利，抱歉，我到底该怎么称呼您？不，随你便。好吧，尊贵的约翰·曼利曾在 2002 年至 2003 年担任加拿大副总理，在 2002 年的皇家访问期间，他是女王访问国会山时的随从，听起来非常官方，但据他所说，整个经历其实，有点索然无味。我在飞机旁遇到了她。我坐过车队，但其实没什么事可做。没有什么机会和她交谈，和她在一起。我的意思是，你不会和女王同车旅行。
She's in her own vehicle. So John Manley says, much like Luciano, he was given this long list of things you're not supposed to do when you meet the queen, like you're supposed to bow, you're supposed to call her, you're majesty stuff like that. So I'm building up to it, and obviously it's weird to ask someone, were you reading Office Script? Okay. But I built up the courage, I asked him, I told him the whole story about Luciano, and John Manley said,
她坐她自己的车。所以约翰·曼利说，和卢西亚诺很像，他也被给了一份长长的清单，列出了见女王时绝对不能做的事，比如你应该鞠躬，应该称呼她为“陛下”之类的事情。所以我正在为此做铺垫，显然去问一个人“你当时是在照剧本读吗”是很奇怪的。好吧。但我鼓起勇气问了他，我把卢西亚诺的整个故事告诉了他，然后约翰·曼利说，
no, he did not have to read office script when he met the queen. Well, I never experienced the palace being that, you know, involved in the details moment by moment. Does that sound plausible to you that like everybody speaking to the queen is reading office script as some kind? Well, it's, my guess is that wasn't dictated by the palace. It was probably dictated by the CBC. Yeah. Yeah. The Queen's coming to our building.
不，他见女王时不需要照着剧本读。嗯，我从未经历过王室对这些细节如此，你知道的，事无巨细地介入。这听起来对你来说合理吗，就像所有跟女王说话的人都在某种程度上照着剧本读？嗯，我的猜测是，那并不是由王室指定的。那很可能是由 CBC 规定的。对。是的。女王要来我们的大楼了。
Here's what, here's how we're going to receive her. Now, somebody may have decided they should tell the palace what they plan to do. So my guess is that was a CBC's plan. Huh. So do you have any theories as to why the CBC would do that? So I asked a few people about this and it seems like the big reason was timing. Like they had less than 15 minutes, they wanted to get to 30 people. It's just a lot more efficient if you script everything out.
这就是我们，这就是我们将要接待她的方式。现在，可能有人决定他们应该把他们计划做的事告诉王室。所以我的猜测那是 CBC 的计划。哦。那你有什么理论能解释为什么 CBC 会这么做吗？所以我问了几个人关于这事，似乎最大的原因是时间。比如他们只有不到 15 分钟，却想让 30 个人都跟她见上。如果把一切都写成剧本，效率会高得多。
But also like the CBC is a public institution. I can see them being worried that if somebody goes off the cuff, they offends the queen. That could be a terrible headline. You know, there's lots of reasons this might have happened, but regardless whatever the reason was that day, everybody was scripted. And so like, how did it go with the CBC? Like did people actually stick to the script? Yeah, so Luciano told me, you know, after all the prep writing the dialect for 30 people, they actually did a run through where Luciano played the queen and went up, I was like, hello, I'm the queen. And the whole visit, after all that, it went totally fine.
但同时也因为 CBC 是一个公共机构。我可以理解他们会担心如果有人脱口而出，冒犯了女王。那可能会成为一个可怕的头条新闻。你知道的，这可能会发生有很多原因，但无论那天出于什么原因，每个人都是按剧本来的。所以，那么在 CBC 的情况怎么样呢？大家真的都按剧本走了吗？对，所以卢西亚诺告诉我，你知道的，在为 30 个人写完对话的所有的筹备工作之后，他们实际上进行了一次彩排，卢西亚诺扮演女王，走过去说，你好，我是女王。经历这一切之后，整个访问过程非常顺利。
It was 12 minutes long. Luciano actually was able to sneak himself into the line to meet the queen. Luciano actually was able to sneak himself into the line to meet the queen. And she had like a emerald necklace, Tierra. And all I could think of was like, oh, this is that real? Like, I guess that's why they have the rule. Because you're so gobsmacked by the jewels, like everyone just, you know, mouth of Gabe says, or those real. Well, yeah, exactly. I mean, Roman, that's why I never ask you about your recording Tierra. I feel like it's kind of an important question. Well, and you should just always assume it's real.
持续了 12 分钟。卢西亚诺甚至成功把自己塞进了见女王的队伍中。卢西亚诺甚至成功把自己塞进了见女王的队伍中。她当时戴着一条祖母绿项链和王冠。我脑子里唯一能想到的就是，哦，这玩意儿是真的吗？我想这就是他们为什么有这个规矩的原因。因为你被珠宝惊艳得目瞪口呆，以至于每个人都，你知道的，目瞪口呆地问，那些是真的吗？好吧，对，没错。我的意思是，罗曼，这就是为什么我从不问你关于你的录音王冠的事。我觉得这是一个相当重要的问题。好吧，你其实应该默认它就是真的。
This is so great. Well, thank you Chris. Thanks, Roman. This is the sound of the longest escalator in the United States. It's at Wheaton Station, which is a stop on Washington DC's Metro Subway System. The escalator is 230 feet long, and it takes about 3 minutes to travel from top to bottom. 99PI's intern Olivia Green lives in DC, and she's gonna tell you about this escalator and some of the war surrounding the metro station that it's a part of. In the length of time, it takes for her
这太棒了。好吧，谢谢你，克里斯。谢谢你，罗曼。这是全美最长的自动扶梯的声音。它位于惠顿车站（Wheaton Station），这是华盛顿特区地铁系统（Metro Subway System）的一个车站。这座扶梯长 230 英尺，从顶部到底部大约需要乘坐 3 分钟。99PI 的实习生奥利维娅·格林住在华盛顿特区，她将向大家讲述这座扶梯，以及它所属地铁站周围的一些怪谈。在她
to ride the escalator. So, here's Olivia. I'm a regular metro commuter, but standing here is always kind of an eerie experience. In addition to the sounds of the machines and just how deep the tunnel goes, if you look up, the walls are curved, gray, and start looking. Engineers chose to build this particular station so deep because the rock in this area is especially soft, so they needed to dig the train tunnels and more solid rock further
乘坐扶梯的时间里。那么，有请奥利维娅。我是一名经常坐地铁的通勤族，但站在这里总有一种诡异的感觉。除了机器的轰鸣声以及隧道有多深之外，如果你抬头看，墙壁是弯曲的、灰色的、呈拱形。工程师们之所以选择把这个特定的车站建得这么深，是因为这一带的岩石特别软，所以他们需要在更深、更坚固的岩石层中
down. The tunnel's visual inspiration came from a team of architects led by a man named Harry Wees back in the 1960s. So prior to taking on Metro, Wees had not worked on a subway system before. This is Zachary Strag, a historian who studied the Washington Metro system. And so as part of this contract, he managed to get a first class around the world trip, spending a lot of time in Western Europe, but also in the Soviet Union, I believe in Japan, looking at subway systems and sketching them rapidly and trying to think about what parts of them could be adapted to Washington.
开挖地铁隧道。隧道的视觉灵感来自于 20世纪 60年代由一个名叫哈里·威斯（Harry Weese）的人领导的建筑师团队。所以在接手地铁项目之前，威斯以前并没有设计过地铁系统。这是扎卡里·施拉格（Zachary Schrag），一位研究华盛顿地铁系统的历史学家。因此，作为这份合同的一部分，他设法获得了一次环球头等舱旅行，在西欧度过了很长时间，我也相信还有苏联和日本，考察地铁系统并迅速将其素描下来，并试图思考它们的哪些部分可以适应华盛顿。
Weas was inspired by those train systems from around the world, and he ended up designing these vaulted underground stations with coffered ceilings that look kind of like a waffle. The stations are lit with hidden lights that cast dramatic shadows. Harry Weas rightly gets tremendous credit for the overall appearance of Metro. It's unforgettable appearance, really.
威斯受到世界各地那些列车系统的启发，他最终设计了这些带有格状天花板的拱形地下车站，看起来有点像华夫饼。车站里点缀着隐藏的灯光，投射出戏剧性的阴影。哈里·威斯理应为地铁的整体外观获得巨大的赞誉。它那令人难忘的外观，确实如此。
But it's important to understand that he was the leader of a team. And a very crucial member of that team was a lighting designer named William Lamb. Lamb was responsible for the lights that shine upwards and illuminate the vault, turning it into a kind of underground sky. I think what we was trying to do was to make the stations seem like a little bit of the outdoors underground. So the vault is a bit like the sky, the granite edges on the platforms might resemble the curbs of a sidewalk. But as I ride the escalator, I can't help but feel like the overall effect of this design isn't always reassuring. It's kind of spooky, and I don't think I'm the only one who feels this way.
但重要的是要明白，他是一个团队的领导者。而那个团队中至关重要的一员是一位名叫威廉·兰姆（William Lamb）的灯光设计师。兰姆负责那些向上照射并照亮拱顶的灯光，将其变成了一种地下天空。我想威斯试图做的是让车站看起来有点像地下的户外。所以拱顶有点像天空，月台上的花岗岩边缘可能类似于人行道的路缘。但当我乘坐自动扶梯时，我禁不住觉得这种设计的总体效果并不总是让人感到安心。这有点诡异，而且我觉得有这种感觉的不止我一个。
In fact, the DC Metro system has inspired quite a bit of extraterrestrial war. You can see hints of it in stations across the city, like small tags of flying saucers on the outsides of stations, and lots of stories, mostly shared on Reddit, of encounters with ghost trains passing by, filled with alien creatures. And while it's mostly playful, there is something about the Metro's design that lends itself to being an imaginative space for its passengers. Zachary Shrag hasn't personally seen any aliens on the Metro, but
事实上，华盛顿特区的地铁系统引发了不少天外怪谈。你可以在全市各地的车站看到它的蛛丝马迹，比如车站外贴着的小飞碟标签，还有很多故事（大部分在红迪网上分享），讲述了偶遇幽灵列车驶过、里面挤满了外星生物的经历。虽然这大多只是开玩笑，但地铁的设计确实有一种特质，使其成为乘客们发挥想象力的空间。扎卡里·施拉格并没有在地铁里亲眼见过任何外星人，但
he still kind of gets it. And so when a train comes in it casts a shadow up on the vault. So there's this dark shadow coming in and slowing down and then speeding up again as it disappears. And here we are at the end of the longest escalator and one of the country's most iconic metro stations. Thanks Olivia, this was great. A few months back, a story went around the internet about a bizarre computer issue from the mid-2000s. It was from a blog post by Microsoft developer Raymond Chen. So a laptop manufacturer came to the Windows team and reported a serious problem. It turns out when they played a song by one specific artist, and in fact it was one specific song, the laptop crashed.
他还是挺能理解的。因此，当一列火车驶入时，它会在拱顶上投下一道阴影。所以有一个黑色的阴影进来，放慢速度，然后随着它消失又加速。我们现在来到了全美最长扶梯的尽头，这也是这个国家最具标志性的地铁车站之一。谢谢奥利维娅，这太棒了。几个月前，互联网上流传着一个关于 2000 年代中期一个离奇电脑故障的故事。它源自微软开发者雷蒙德·陈（Raymond Chen）的一篇博客文章。当时，一家笔记本电脑制造商来到 Windows 团队，报告了一个严重的问题。原来，当他们播放某个特定艺术家的某首歌时，而且事实上是一首特定的歌，笔记本电脑就会死机。
But things got even weirder when they started testing it out. They found that this song crashed some of their competitors' laptops also. But the weirdest thing was that if you played this song crashed some of their competitors' laptops also. But the weirdest thing was that if you played this song, it not only crashed the laptop that was playing it, it also crashed a laptop that was sitting next to it that wasn't playing the song at all. No, before I play this song, if you have a laptop that's over 15 years old, you might want to cover its ears.
但当他们开始测试时，事情变得更加诡异了。他们发现这首歌也会导致他们某些竞争对手的笔记本电脑死机。但最诡异的是，如果你播放这首歌，不仅会使正在播放它的笔记本电脑死机，还会使旁边放着的一台根本没有播放这首歌的笔记本电脑死机。等等，在我播放这首歌之前，如果你有一台使用超过 15 年的笔记本电脑，你可能想捂住它的耳朵。
This is Janet Jackson's 1989 smash hit, Rhythm Nation. Now I found this story fascinating and bizarre, but even after reading the blog post, I still didn't really understand what was going on, so I asked our engineer, Martin Gonzalez, to come explain. Hey, what's up? Hey, so what do you have for me? Okay. Well, disclaimer upfront, I'm a music school dropout, not a computer scientist. I would never do it anyway.
这是珍妮·杰克逊 1989 年的热门轰动单曲《节奏国度》（Rhythm Nation）。我觉得这个故事既迷人又离奇，但即使在读了这篇博客文章之后，我还是不太明白到底发生了什么，所以我请我们的工程师马丁·冈萨雷斯来解释一下。嘿，最近怎么样？嘿，那你给我准备了什么？好的。好吧，首先声明，我是个音乐学校辍学生，不是计算机科学家。我无论如何都不会去干那个。
So here's my best understanding of what happened. These engineers were trying to figure out how this particular song was crashing all these different computers. And they narrowed it down to the hard drive. So all the laptops use the same model of hard drive. Okay. So computer storage has come a long way since then and solid state drives are in a lot of laptops now.
所以这是我对所发生事情的最好理解。这些工程师试图弄清楚这首歌究竟是如何导致所有这些不同的计算机死机的。他们把范围缩小到了硬盘。所以所有的笔记本电脑都使用同一型号的硬盘。好吧。所以计算机存储自那时以来已经取得了长足的进步，固态硬盘现在广泛应用于许多笔记本电脑中。
But the basic concept of a hard drive has been around since the 60s. There's a spinning platter with a data and an arm over it that reads and writes the data. So think of like a really tiny little record player inside of a box. I mean, I remember that you could actually hear the spinning of the drive. It would spin fast when you'd started up or click on a file. It was a mechanical thing you felt. Yeah, like my 2005 era power book would sound kind of like this. Yeah, totally.
但硬盘的基本概念自 60 年代以来就一直存在。里面有一个带数据的旋转盘片，还有一个在其上方读取和写入数据的磁头。所以可以把它想象成盒子里一个非常微小的微型留声机。我的意思是，我记得你实际上能听到硬盘的旋转声。当你启动它或点击文件时它会高速旋转。那是你能感受到的机械装置。对，就像我 2005 年左右的苹果笔记本听起来会有点像这样。对，完全是这样。
And so without getting too into the weeds of the physics, it's spinning fast enough to actually hit a musical note. And the pitch it makes depends on the speed of the hard drive. So the hard drive has all these resonant frequencies that are actually musical notes. And if you played one loud enough, you can actually knock the hard drive has all these resonant frequencies that are actually musical notes. And if you played one loud enough, you could actually knock the hard drive physically out of whack. You know, like the trope of like an opera singer shattering glass with a high note.
所以，在不深入探讨物理学的情况下，它的旋转速度快到足以击中一个音符。它产生的音高取决于硬盘的速度。所以硬盘有所有这些共振频率，它们实际上就是音符。如果你把其中一个音符放得足够大，你实际上可以把硬盘敲击得——如果你把其中一个音符放得足够大，你实际上可以在物理上把硬盘敲出毛病。你知道的，就像歌剧演员用高音震碎玻璃的梗一样。
Same idea. Okay, you got it. Yeah, so when the laptop manufacturer was trying to pinpoint the problem, they figured out that rhythm nation had a frequency in it that was breaking these hard drives that way. And they even narrowed it down to one particular model of hard drive that was nation had a frequency in it that was breaking these hard drives that way. And they even narrowed it down to one particular model of hard drive that was used in a bunch of different companies laptops. But like why just this one song?
同样的道理。好吧，你懂了。是的，所以当笔记本电脑制造商试图查明问题所在时，他们发现《节奏国度》里有一个频率会以这种方式损坏这些硬盘。他们甚至将其缩小到某一个特定型号的硬盘，该硬盘被多家不同公司的笔记本电脑所使用。但为什么偏偏只有这一首歌呢？
Cause I can't imagine it's so, I mean, I love Janet Jackson, but it's so musically innovative that it creates a sound that no other songs have ever created, you know what I'm saying? Yeah, so there's two big reasons that it creates a sound that no other songs have ever created. You know what I'm saying? Yeah, so there's two big reasons why only Janna Jackson's song has this frequency. Okay.
因为我无法想象它是如此——我的意思是，我喜欢珍妮·杰克逊，但它是如此具有音乐创新性，以至于它创造了一种其他歌曲从未创造过的声音，你懂我的意思吗？是的，所以之所以只有珍妮·杰克逊的歌有这个频率，有两个主要原因。你懂我的意思吗？是的，所以为什么只有珍妮·杰克逊的歌有这个频率，有两个重大原因。好的。
The first one is the song is sped up very slightly to make it a little more exciting. This is a really common trick. So here's the speed the song was actually recorded at. And here's the slightly faster final version. Wow, I didn't know that at all. That's amazing. It does work. I like the first one I was like, oh, this is the song I recognize.
第一个原因是这首歌的速度被稍微加快了一点，让它听起来更带劲一点。这是一个非常常见的把戏。所以这是这首歌实际录制时的速度。这是稍微加快后的最终版本。哇，我一点都不知道。这太惊人了。确实管用。我听第一首的时候就在想，哦，这是我认得的那首歌。
And I'm like, oh, no, it's the second one that I really recognize. Yeah, that's great. Yeah, it makes it a little more exciting, little grooveier. So this is recorded in the era of tape machines. And you can hear that when you speed the tape up, it also goes up in pitch. So the notes in rhythm nation fall between the ones you'd normally hear in a pop hit. Oh, oh, okay. I see. So that's why the song contains frequencies that other songs might not have ever had. Exactly. And when you first asked me about this, I naturally went, well, what is that
然后我想，哦不，第二首才是我真正认得的。对，这太棒了。是的，这让它听起来更带劲、更带感。所以这是在磁带机时代录制的。你可以听到，当你加速磁带时，它的音高也会上升。所以《节奏国度》中的音符落在了你在流行金曲中通常听到的那些音符之间。哦，哦，好吧。我明白了。所以这就是为什么这首歌包含了一些其他歌曲可能从未拥有的频率。完全正确。而当你刚问我这个问题时，我自然而然地想，那究竟是什么
frequency? I was doing a little research and this YouTuber, Adam Neely, explained the speed change and he theorized that it moved the bass notes into the frequency range that would just vibrate this platter out of control. Right. And this makes sense to me because, you know, if you're at a show or you're just like walking down an neighborhood and a car is playing loud music, it is the bass that you feel like in your stardom. Like that's what's really rattling you.
频率？我做了一点研究，这个油管博主亚当·尼利（Adam Neely）解释了速度变化，他推测它将低音移动到了刚好能使这个盘片失控振动的频率范围内。对。这对我来说很有道理，因为，你知道的，如果你在看演出，或者你只是走在某个街区，有一辆车在放大声音乐，让你在骨子里感受到的是低音。就像那是真正震撼你的东西。
Right, right, but here's why I think it might not actually be the base. Like, remember when there was that Mazda virus and people were like, maybe Roman's voice is so easy it's breaking the stairs. Like, the amount of base you would need to break a laptop sitting next to it would be way beyond the capability of a 2005 era laptop.
对，对，但这就是为什么我认为它可能实际上不是低音。比如，还记得当时有那个麦斯威尔病毒（Mazda virus）的时候，人们都在想，也许罗曼的声音太厉害了，把楼梯都震碎了。比如，要震碎旁边放着的笔记本电脑所需的低音量，将远远超出 2005 年代笔记本电脑的能力范围。
Like, you need some Jamaica-sucking subwoofers. Yeah. And, you know, also the baseline moves around a lot. It doesn't hang out on any one sustained frequency for very long. Yeah. So, I looked up this study of laptop hard drive resonant frequencies and saw that there's a couple
你需要那种能把牙齿震松的低音炮。对。而且，你知道的，低音线条也经常变动。它不会在任何一个持续的频率上停留太久。对。所以，我查阅了关于笔记本电脑硬盘共振频率的研究，发现有几个频率
around 2000 hertz, which is the same whiny high pitch that the hard drive I played earlier was making. So that's why I suspect it might actually be that frequency that was the issue. And so does rhythm nation have that frequency buried in there? Yep, it is not buried. It is loud and clear. It's these couple of sustained piercings synthesizer notes. Whoa. Yeah, and this third sustained one is at right about 2000 Hertz, which if that was the
在大约 2000 赫兹左右，这与我刚才播放的硬盘发出的刺耳高音是同一个音高。这就是为什么我怀疑这实际上可能是导致问题的那个频率。那么《节奏国度》里真的藏着那个频率吗？是的，它没有被藏起来。它是响亮而清晰的。就是这几个持续的、刺耳的合成器音符。哇。是的，第三个持续的音符大约在 2000 赫兹，如果那是那个特定硬盘的共振频率，它在歌里出现的频率足够高，以至于完全可以把它震出毛病。而且微小的笔记本电脑扬声器确实能清晰地发出这个频率。所以如果你把它开得足够大声，它是有可能影响到相邻的硬盘的。太酷了。哇。是的，里面还有另一种听起来有点疯狂的声音，可能也是一个因素。
resonant frequency of that one particular hard drive, it happens enough in the song where it could totally knock it out of whack. And tiny little laptop speakers can really blast this frequency clearly. So it would be possible if you played it loud enough that it could affect a neighboring hard drive. That's so cool. Wow. Yeah, and there's this other kind of crazy sound in there that might be a factor as well.
我的意思是，那听起来本身就像一个坏掉的硬盘。对，对。这是一个非常奇怪的声音。就像一个胡乱循环的踩镲之类的东西。在同一个 2000 赫兹的区域周围有很多能量。所以如果我的理论是对的，这两种声音加在一起确实会引发很多混乱。所以这是一连串惊人的巧合。这首歌碰巧有这些不常见的音高。它们与
I mean, that itself sounds like a broken hard drive. Right, right. And it's a very weird sound. It's like a jankily looped high-hat kind of thing. It's got a lot of energy around that same 2,000 hertz area. So if my theory is right, those two sounds together could really cause a lot of chaos. So this is an amazing string of quenstances. So that this song happened to have these uncommon pitches. They lined up exactly with the frequencies
某特定型号硬盘的频率完全吻合。所以这真的是太巧了。是的，在博客文章中，雷蒙德·陈说其实有一个相当简单的解决方案。他们编写了一个非常陡峭的均衡器（EQ）截断，专门针对有问题的频率，而不影响任何其他频率。而且精确去除单个高频比去除低频要容易得多。所以如果我把 2000 赫兹完全从这首歌里抽掉，听起来会是这样的。我是应该听出有什么不同吗？我真的没有。没有。好吧，这正是重点。
of one specific model of hard drive. So it's really something. Yeah, and in the blog post, Raymond Chen said there was actually a fairly simple solution. They programmed in a really sharp EQ cut that just targeted the problem frequency without affecting any of the other ones. And it's way easier to narrowly remove individual high frequencies than bass ones. So here's what it sounds like if I just took 2000 Hertz completely out of the song. Am I supposed to be here in a difference? I really don't. No. Well, that's exactly the point.
唯一的区别在于那个合成器部分几乎听不见了，但透过这些破烂的笔记本电脑扬声器，你根本不可能注意到其中的区别。这真是一个绝妙的解决方案。我很喜欢。是的。而有趣的部分是，雷蒙德说也有一种可能，这种代码仍然潜藏在某些旧型号的笔记本电脑或不再使用的硬盘中，
Like the only difference is that that synthesizer part is almost inaudible, but it would be totally impossible to notice the difference through these crappy laptops speakers. That's such a great solution. I love it. Yeah. And the fighting part is Raymond says there's also a possibility this code is just still lurking out there, cutting out frequencies on certain models of laptop for hard drives that aren't used anymore. That's so funny to me that there's this code that may be still out there in hard drives,
这太搞笑了，居然还有这种代码可能仍然存在于硬盘中，这种遗留代码只会让你的扬声器稍微贬值一点，只是为了保护我们免受珍妮·杰克逊的侵害。是的，那些写下这段代码的人早就全都不在了。没人敢去碰它，以防弄坏了什么，它只是 2000 年代中期的遗迹。对啊，不，这太搞笑了。好吧，这太完美了。非常感谢你向我解释这些。
this legacy code that is deprecating your speakers just a little bit, just to guard us from Janet Jackson. Yeah, the people who put it in there are all long gone. No one dares touch it in case it breaks something, just a remnant of the mid-2000s. Yeah, no, it's so funny. Okay, this is perfect. Thank you so much for explaining this to me.
这真是一个有趣的故事。好了，就到这儿。再见，罗曼。[♪ 片尾音乐播放] 在插播之后，海狸空降行动。我的意思是，你怎么能不为这个回来呢？我现在和数字总监兼《99%隐形城市》合著者库尔特·科尔斯特德（Kurt Kohlstedt）在一起。嗨，库尔特。嗨，罗曼。你今年的迷你故事是什么？
It is such a fun story. Yeah, it's a wrap. Bye, Robin. [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING After the break, Operation Beaver dropped. I mean, how could you not come back for that? So I'm here with Kurt Colstead, Digital director and co-author of the 99% invisible city. Hey Kurt. Hey Rowan. What is your many story this year?
几年前，爱达荷州鱼类和游戏部门的一名员工翻出了一段拍摄于 20世纪 40年代末的长篇失传档案视频，名为《未来的皮毛》（Fur for the Future）。这部电影被错误归档和贴错标签已经有半个多世纪了，它在办公室里获得了一种传奇般的品质，原因我们稍后会讲到。但基本上，它记录了爱达荷州为了保护目的而重新安置特定哺乳动物物种的做法，包括麝鼠、貂和海狸。影片从一个非常简单的地方开始，只是解释了常规的异地安置项目，
A few years back, an employee of Idaho Fish and Game turned up this long lost archival video filmed in the late 1940s entitled Fur for the Future. Now this film had been misfiled and mislabeled for over half a century and it gained kind of legendary quality around the office, for reasons we'll get into it a bit. But basically, it documents Idaho's practice of relocating specific mammal species for conservation purposes, including muskrats and martens and beavers. And the film starts off simply enough, just explaining conventional relocation projects
就像这个一样。到 20世纪 30年代，重新安置海狸实际上已经成为一种相当普遍的做法，在私人土地上，它们被活捉，并转移到遥远的高山湖泊和溪流中。到 20世纪 30年代，重新安置海狸实际上已经成为一种相当普遍的做法，部分原因是为了让它们避开不断扩张的人类，但生态学家也越来越清楚地认识到，海狸对生态系统极其重要。它们帮助建立和维护湿地、减少侵蚀、创造栖息地等等。好吧，所以部分是为了让海狸远离人类，但也有部分是为了保护这个物种的数量。没错，我们谈论的是当时陷入严重危急状态的一个物种。所以作为背景，当殖民者刚到达美洲时，有数亿只美洲海狸。但到了 20 世纪之交，这个数字
like this one. By the 1930s, relocating beavers was actually a pretty common practice, private lands, they are live trapped, and move to distant mountain lakes and streams. By the 1930s, relocating beavers was actually a pretty common practice, and partly this was to get them out of the way of encroaching humans, but it also had become increasingly clear to ecologists that beavers were hugely important to ecosystems. They helped establish and maintain wetlands, reduced erosion, created habitats, and so on. Okay, so it was in part to keep the beavers clear of people, but also in part to preserve the population. Right, and we're talking about a population in serious crisis at this point. So for context, when colonists first arrived in America, there were hundreds of millions of American beavers. But by the turn of the 20th century, that number
已经骤降至大约 10万只。因此，自然而然地，保护主义者希望在各地播下小规模的种群，试图让数量重新回升。好吧，那么这些海狸是如何被重新安置的呢？嗯，通常它们只是被捕捉、装进板条箱，然后用卡车运到路上的某个地方。但在许多情况下，转移海狸的最佳地点非常遥远，位于几乎没有道路或小径的偏远荒野地带。因此，诸如自然资源部之类的机构尝试了各种各样的解决方案，包括
had dropped to around 100,000. And so conservationists naturally wanted to seed small populations all over the place to try to build those numbers back up. Okay, so how were these beavers relocated? Well, often they were just caught, created, and taken by trucks somewhere up the road. But in a lot of cases, the best places to the move beavers, were really far out there, located in remote stretches of wilderness with few, if any, roads or trails. And so agencies like the Department of Natural Resources tried all kinds of solutions, including
将装着海狸的箱子绑在马和骡子的背上。然后由人带着这些驮兽，有时甚至带着它们的活体货物深入荒野数天。正如你所想象的那样，所有卷入其中的动物都不喜欢这样。你是说把愤怒的海狸和板条箱绑在马上，它们根本不喜欢那样？没有人喜欢那样。没有人喜欢那样。这倒也合理。是的，事实上情况是如此糟糕，以至于有些以这种方式被转移的海狸其实根本没能在旅程中存活下来。我猜它们基本上就是被吓死的。
strapping boxes of beavers to the backs of horses and mules. And these pack animals were then led by people, sometimes for for days deep into the wilderness with their live cargo. And as you might imagine, none of the animals involved in this like this. You mean angry beavers and crates strap the horses and they know like that? Nobody liked that. Nobody liked that. It's fair enough. Yeah, and it was so bad in fact that some of the beavers that were moved around this way didn't actually survive the journey. I assume they were just essentially scared to death.
将装着河狸的箱子绑在马和骡子的背上。这些驮兽随后由人牵着，带着它们活生生的货物，有时要在荒野中走上好几天。正如你所想象的那样，所有参与其中的动物都不喜欢这样。你是说板条箱里的河狸很生气，绑在马身上，它们就像那样？没有人喜欢那样。没有人喜欢那样。这倒也很合理。是的，事实上情况太糟糕了，以至于有些以这种方式被转移的河狸实际上并没有熬过这段旅程。我猜它们基本上是被吓死了。
Oh, that's awful. And of course the horses are spooked too. It just wasn't a good time. And so finally, in the late 1940s, this employee of Idaho Fish and Game began trying to figure out how to relocate beavers more safely. In this case, to a very remote part of the state, which has since come to be known as the Frank Church River of no return wilderness. The Frank Church River of no return wilderness. Okay. That sounds very remote. Yes. Yes. Very far out there. I think there's a warning in the name. I think it's probably best if you don't wander out there. So, yeah, no return.
哦，太糟糕了。当然，马也被吓到了。这实在不是个好时机。因此，在20世纪40年代末，爱达荷州鱼类和野生动物管理局的一位雇员开始琢磨如何更安全地重新安置海狸。在这个案例中，是要把它们送到该州一个非常偏远的地区，后来那里被称为“弗兰克·丘奇不归河荒野”。弗兰克·丘奇不归河荒野。好的。听起来非常偏远。是的。是的，非常偏远。我想名字里就带个警告。我想你最好不要去那里闲逛。所以，是的，有去无回。
And it's hard to get beavers out there too, right? And so they had to start thinking outside the proverbial box and work on faster and cheaper and ultimately safer ways to ship dozens of beavers into the middle of nowhere. And in the end, they came up with this pretty wild idea. On the shores of the atlake, our crates full of beavers, part of a shipment to be dropped by parachute from an airplane. Okay, so again, this straight. They've got these boxes full of beavers that they're going to drop with parachutes into the wilderness. How did they settle on this as the way to do this? Well, it was a lot of circumstance involved in
要把海狸送到那儿也很难，对吧？因此，他们不得不跳出陈旧的思维框架，寻找更快、更便宜、最终也更安全的方法，将几十只海狸运到荒郊野岭。最后，他们想出了一个相当疯狂的主意。在阿特湖的岸边，摆满了装满海狸的板条箱，这是一批准备从飞机上用降落伞空投的货物。好吧，再理清一下。他们有这些装满海狸的箱子，准备用降落伞把它们投放到荒野中。他们是怎么决定用这种方法来完成这件事的呢？嗯，这其中有很多机缘巧合
the decision. Like, for example, this was the post-war era, and so they were looking around for available materials and realized they could secure some World War II parachutes for pretty cheap at this point, right? They were not being used anymore, okay? And so with those in hand, they then worked on designing a delivery box that would open once it landed to let out the beavers. And they considered some pretty crazy ideas for that too, like using a kind of wood that would be easy for the beavers to chew so that there wouldn't need to be a door. They would just let
促成了这个决定。比如，当时是战后时期，所以他们在四处寻找可用的材料，并意识到他们可以以相当便宜的价格买到一些二战时期的降落伞，对吧？这些降落伞当时已经不再使用了，好吧？手头有了这些降落伞后，他们便开始设计一种投递箱，这种箱子在着陆后会自动打开，把海狸放出来。为了这个，他们也考虑了一些相当疯狂的想法，比如使用一种容易被海狸咬烂的木头，这样就不需要门了。它们只要自己
themselves out. But they realized there could be a problem if they got working on that, you know, before they were dropped from the airplane. That? That would have dropped in and midair. Right. Well, either way, it's a problem because either they chew their way out while the plane is flying and then there's beavers wreaking havoc all over your airplane or even worse, maybe, I don't even know, is that they chew their way while they're floating down and then that would be just a mess. That would be terrible.
爬出来就行。但他们意识到，如果在把它们从飞机上投下去之前，它们就开始咬箱子，那可能会出问题。那个？那就会在半空中掉下来。没错。不管怎样，这都是个问题，因为要么它们在飞机飞行时就咬破箱子逃出来，然后海狸会在你的飞机里大闹天宫；或者更糟糕的是——我甚至不知道会不会这样——它们在往下飘落的过程中就把箱子咬破了，那场面一定会一团糟。那太可怕了。
Yeah. I mean, certainly for the beavers, that would be the worst. And so they pretty quickly abandoned that approach. And what they landed on instead was this fairly plain wooden box with a rope and hinge system that would pop the door open automatically on impact. Into the drop box, nearly ready for that flight back into the mountain. And the box has this array of circular air holes. It kind of looks like a giant block of Swiss cheese.
是的。我的意思是，对海狸来说肯定是最糟糕的。所以他们很快就放弃了那种方法。他们最终确定下来的是一个相当朴素的木箱，配有绳索和铰链系统，能在着陆时自动弹开箱门。落入空投箱，几乎准备好飞回山区了。箱子上有一排圆形的通气孔。它看起来有点像一块巨大的瑞士奶酪。
The drop crates are loaded into the airplane. Perisshoots are attached to cargo lines. Two to a crate, no as arc style, because the point is to get them to start a colony. 10 boxes to a load, 20 beaver, ready for the flight to mountain meadows. And then they're off, heading toward the river of no return. The plane makes a careful approach, ready for the flight to mountain meadows. And then they're off heading toward the river of no return. The plane makes a careful approach, ready for the drop.
空投板条箱被装入飞机。降落伞连接到货运线上。每个箱子装两只，不是诺亚方舟式的，因为目的是让它们繁衍一个族群。每架次运载10个箱子，20只海狸，准备飞往山间草地。然后它们出发了，飞向不归河。飞机小心翼翼地接近，准备空投。飞往山间草地的飞行准备就绪。然后它们出发了，飞向不归河。飞机小心翼翼地接近，准备空投。
Now into the air and down may swing, down to the ground near a stream or a lake. And because the planes are flying so low, the shoots open basically right away, and then land pretty gently, at which point. The box opens and a most unusual and novel trip ends for Mr. Beaver. He's on his way now. His nose and his instinct tell him where to find the water. There's room here for a new home.
现在升空并向下摇摆，降落在小溪或湖泊附近的地面上。由于飞机飞得很低，降落伞几乎立刻就会打开，然后相当轻柔地着陆，此时箱子会打开，海狸先生一段极其不寻常和新奇的旅程就此结束。它现在上路了。它的鼻子和本能会告诉它去哪里找水。这里有建立新家的空间。
This is amazing. And so did they know this would work? I mean, how much testing did they do before they just started throwing beavers off of planes? They did a fair amount of testing actually. Their primary test candidate was this beaver aptly named Geronimo and apparently Geronimo got so used to these flights. He started just waiting for the crew to come and pick him up after each lighting. Yeah. And thanks in part to these tests, they determined that the optimal altitude for a drop was around 500 to 800 feet. And this is a bit obvious, but ideally in low wind conditions. Well, yeah, of course, you don't want to drop your fevers in high winds. Yeah. No, definitely not. I mean, but I'm glad to hear that they put a good amount of thought
这太惊人了。那么他们知道这行得通吗？我的意思是，在开始把海狸从飞机上扔下去之前，他们做了多少测试？实际上他们做了相当多的测试。他们的主要测试对象是一只名叫杰罗尼莫的海狸，显然杰罗尼莫已经习惯了这些飞行。每次降落后，它就开始等工作人员来接它。是的。部分归功于这些测试，他们确定空投的最佳高度大约是500到800英尺。这有点显而易见，但最好是在微风条件下。嗯，是的，当然，你可不想在大风天空投海狸。嗯，对，绝对不想。我的意思是，但我很高兴听到他们对此进行了深思熟虑
into this, you know. Yeah, no, no, they really did. And not only into the production of these crates and the kind of design of this experimental relocation process, but also into documenting it all. And so, you know, somebody, as part of this program, had the brilliant idea of filming this, everything from the box design to the field tests to the actual deployments in 1950. And so this video is really rich, resulting in this thing that got lost for a long time but is now out in the world and just the world is better for it. That's amazing.
你知道的。是的，不，不，他们真的这么做了。不仅在这些板条箱的生产和这种实验性重新安置过程的设计上，而且在记录这一切方面也是如此。所以，你知道的，作为这个项目的一部分，有人有个绝妙的主意，把这一切拍成视频，从箱子设计、现场测试到1950年的实际部署。所以这段视频内容非常丰富，造就了这样一段曾经丢失了很久但现在终于面世的影像，世界也因此变得更美好了。这太棒了。
So in the end, how many beavers did they actually relocate in this way? In the end, they air dropped a total of 76 beavers. And thanks to all of that design and testing and planning, only one beaver perished. 75 of them made it to the ground safe and sound. And so the program was a success. These beavers started multiplying and spreading out and really redeveloping the local ecosystem.
那么最终，他们实际上以这种方式重新安置了多少只海狸？最后，他们总共空投了76只海狸。由于所有这些设计、测试和规划，只有一只海狸不幸身亡。75只安全无恙地抵达地面。所以这个项目非常成功。这些海狸开始繁殖、扩散，并真正重建了当地的生态系统。
Wow. But on a grander scale, perhaps the more lasting legacy of this project is all the other animal airlifts that are now normal today, like suspending goats from helicopters to relocate them, or dumping tons of fish from the bellies of plains into lakes to repopulate them. Well, this is cool stuff, and it's fun to imagine a bunch of beavers floating gently down in boxes, seeding the landscape. And you know when I was telling somebody this story a couple days ago, they told me that
哇。但在更宏大的层面上，这个项目或许更持久的遗产是现在日常生活中常见的其他动物空运，比如用直升机吊运山羊来重新安置它们，或者把成吨的鱼从飞机腹部倾倒到湖泊中以恢复它们的种群。嗯，这真是酷炫的东西，想象一群海狸乘着箱子轻轻漂浮，将生机播撒在大地上，是一件很有趣的事。你知道几天前我把这个故事讲给某人听时，他们告诉我
they were picturing beavers with little parachutes on them. And honestly, it's such a brilliant mental image. And I kind of wish that's what they'd done. Obviously, it probably would not have worked as well and would have caused all kinds of problems, but it's so cute. Like beaver paratroopers, just like, you can imagine the single file like hopping out of the plane, go, go, go.
他们脑补的是海狸背着小降落伞的画面。老实说，这个脑补画面太精彩了。我甚至有点希望他们当年就是这么做的。显然，这可能不会那么顺利，还会引起各种各样的问题，但它太可爱了。就像海狸伞兵一样，你可以想象它们排成单行从飞机上跳出去，走，走，走。
You know, I love it. Yeah. If only. So it's only. It seems like they landed on the right solution, but it is fun to imagine. It will be for a pair of true words. It really is.
你知道的，我太喜欢了。是的。要是那样的话就好了。所以，看起来他们找到了正确的解决方案，但想象一下还是很有趣的。对伞兵海狸来说也是如此。确实如此。
Just taking over the river of no other place. This is awesome. Well, thank you so much, Kurt. I appreciate it. Yeah, thank you. 99% of the visible was produced this week by Chris Barubey, Martin Gonzales, Kurt Colstead, and our intern Olivia Green. This is her last week with us as an intern, she will be missed. Music by director Sound Swan Rihall.
占领不归河的其他地方。这太棒了。好的，非常感谢你，库尔特。我很感激。是的，谢谢你。本周的“99%无形”由克里斯·巴鲁比、马丁·冈萨雷斯、库尔特·科尔斯泰德和我们的实习生奥利维亚·格林制作。这是她作为实习生的最后一周，我们会想念她的。音乐由导演声音天鹅里霍尔提供。
Delaney Hall is a senior editor for us of the team includes Vivian Leigh, Christopher Johnson, Emmett Fitzgerald, Loshamadon, Jason Deleone, Jacob Moltenon Omedina, Kelly Prime, Joe Rosenberg, Sophia Klassker, and me Roman Mars. A special thanks this week to Alex Malodko, Jonathan Torrance, Raymond Shen,
德兰妮·霍尔是我们团队的高级编辑，成员包括维维安·李、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、埃mett·菲茨杰拉德、洛沙马顿、杰森·德莱昂、雅各布·莫尔特诺恩·奥梅迪纳、凯利·普莱姆、乔·罗森伯格、索菲亚·克拉斯克以及我罗曼·马尔斯。本周要特别感谢亚历克斯·马洛特科、乔纳森·托伦斯、雷蒙德·沈，
and my sister, Lee Morris, her book is called Golden. You should buy it. We are a part of the Stitcher and Serious Exam podcast family. Now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building, in beautiful, uptown, Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 9-9-PI org. We're on Instagram, Reddit, and TikTok too. You can find links to other Stitcher shows I love, as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. The world is alive, we'll be alive, we'll be alive, we'll be alive, we'll be alive, To see the success of time
以及我的妹妹莉·莫里斯，她的书叫《黄金》。你应该买一本。我们是Stitcher和SiriusXM播客家族的一部分。现在总部设在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市上城区潘多拉大厦以北六个街区。你可以在Facebook上找到这个节目并参与讨论。你可以在Twitter上@我（@Roman Mars），也可以@节目（@99PI org）。我们也在Instagram、Reddit和TikTok上。你可以在99PI.org上找到我喜欢的其他Stitcher节目的链接，以及99PI的每一期过往节目。世界生生不息，我们将生生不息，我们将生生不息，我们将生生不息，我们将生生不息，去见证时间的成功
To see the success of time There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
去见证时间的成功 本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。